في الاثناء نقلت وكاله تاسع عن مدير القسم
الثاني لبلدان رابطه الدول المستقله
بوزاره الخارجيه الروسيه اليكسي بولي شوك
تاكيده وان المناورات العسكريه مع
بيلاروسيا دفاعيه بطبيعتها ويتم اجرائها
لثني الخصوم المحتملين عن التصعيد حسب
قوله قولي شكاره الى نشر وحدات اضافيه من
القوات المشتركه في بيلاروسيا منذ اكتوبر
الماضي فضلا عن اجراء فعاليات تنسيق
قتاليه وتدريبات ومناورات على حد تعبيرها
الروسيه ان العقيده العسكريه لدوله او
لدول الاتحاد بين روسيا وبيلا روسيا
تفترضوا ان استخدام القوه العسكريه ضد اي
دوله مشاركه يعتبر تعديا على دول الاتحاد
كلها من وجهه نظر قانونيه فان استخدام
القوه العسكريه من طرف نظام كياف او غزوه
اوكرانيا لاوكرانيا لاراضي بلا روسيا او
روسيا
يعتبر وان سببا كافيا لاتخابه اجراءات رد
جماعيه